[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday hello there
how's it going
it's going pretty good heck yeah we are
here for another community Fridays later
in the day than usual and it's a real
community Fridays this time if for real
oh yeah that's true I forgot we haven't
been doing because we haven't actually
fought anyone in a long time we're
played with them you know we're here to
fight with you guys we're gonna play
some Mortal Kombat yeah yeah yeah so
hopefully you guys are prepared to throw
down then you've been practicing all day
I have been playing all day alright just
show this up here yeah we're gonna lobby
GameSpot is the name of the lobby yeah
if you guys want to play with us we're
playing on ps4 so come on in come on and
fight us
first-come first-serve apparently
there's you can put a hundred people in
these lobbies you couldn't the old ones
I haven't seen anything in these ones
yet okay so this is also a bit of a
science episode and that we're learning
how the multiplayer works all right yeah
I think hopefully some other people
there's a no Persia was very excited
jumping yeah hang out here ready to
fight out hey what's up everybody
yes hi how's it going how's everyone's
Friday going well we can once Friday I'm
sleeping yeah you you've been even doing
some some real relaxed movie going move
it going I just got out of Avengers snow
spoilers
yeah miss poison Jack that's the big
campaign
I'm from Turkey in Turkey oh man we're
getting the turkey peepers is here you
fight perjure while you're waiting
I'm down with so we've basically been
fighting like for them we've been
fighting for a while now yeah that one
millisecond lag response time I'm here
for it standard how do you join so you
just go to room and then you should be
able to search out GameSpot right failed
to send challenge oh I'd sent it so fast
that it kicks her out what I guess we
have it on ps4 search a room and you
should be able to find GameSpot
hopefully she gets back in here I'm
about there we go I'm down let's just do
a vs. match standard let's make it
happen I'm ready to get worked his legs
are a bit dicey even in league hey you
know it's fine alright so I'm gonna
start off with my favorite character
because I'm not very great with him but
I like him you're not great with Johnny
Cage I mean I there's a lot more that I
could be doing with him but I'm still
working on it
the big problem is as we all know the
towers have been real difficult and kind
of challenging yeah and I've been
sending my AI BOTS out to do all my work
for me so yeah the plays kind of been my
thing like you played 200 matches and
scorpion I'm like
really haven't though haven't though
your oh did we not check the sound it
got switched
oh we might have to back out and switch
it think we can fix that we did it
that's a weird issue you get I can I
won't be holed up there the meetings I
mean I'm not I'm not gonna be able to
hit you firm uh I'm also pretty stoked
about oh well this game like action
please dad
well this just means we get to sit here
and focus on the music if you don't know
it's actually a rearrangement not my
contract the one voice line that gets
through
[Applause]
No there we go see that's that's no more
hand I'm not good at the like down down
back fat back forward moves yeah like I
can't get me right Oh move their pit
just a little bit okay oh yeah because
they got like the the weird like you can
sort of fit the camera inside of those
yes I got moved it a little bit just so
we could even still see our bars
oh man first fatality of the day I
didn't botch it nice high grass was a
good fight
should we back out and fix this after
this fight though
sure you think you know the buttons
quicker after after the fatality goes
off I'll let you get to it someone a
fumble otherwise oh yeah we don't even
hear Johnny Cage yeah it's winds it's a
real weird setup
well here if you if you change the thing
right now we could we could get it back
I want to give you a chance right in
front of everyone waiting for an arrow
on here you go hot tip everyone's gonna
see my theme John Luke and be exposed
okay and now we should be able to hear
everything a network error occurred I
might even cuz I popped out maybe you
could play hey this might be a thing we
bring back we're gonna remake the room
really quick hey nothing else going on
next Friday it's true maybe we'll do a
more comment run back by updating game
data player status sorry if you were in
there and you got kicked out set it up
again treating friends list
don't need to find my friends is this
fine so I don't know if it's case
sensitive or not so I should probably
not do the inner caps bite Griffin ding
- heck yeah I'm all about that grim
fandago C room no no I suppose yeah and
it's a good theme top top themes when
are we gonna do our gallery of failed to
create room cool when we do our gallery
of top PS n themes for your PlayStation
4 oh man we should definitely do that
games definitely worth dang that Prince
Diana one that was wild back out hit
again I'm just going to do let's just do
it all lowercase just to be doubly safe
[Music]
watch this is like Friday when everyone
gets home is the time when the internet
just starts ok we're back we're good
maybe it's because we tried to make a
room that was named the same thing as
one that might still be like lagged
alright so now it's just GameSpot all
lowercase letters super easy super high
before I got people showing us yeah
Johnny Cage heck yeah Aaron black heck
yeah fantastic in here purchase in here
do some fights I'm gonna challenge Corey
cuz they're the first person in here and
if you guys want to do you can fight
against each other while we're fighting
other people but once we get people into
the room I'll just let whoever
challenges me first as long as you don't
do it twice fight me
do it that way I'll go with with Johnny
Cage again cuz I'm gonna keep you boy
keep going with Johnny Cage until I was
and then I'll be able to old Johnny Cage
and young Johnny Cage I'm gonna go with
the The Fight Club see I won I won the
first fight and that was picking the
stage ready for it can I pull yeah
anyone can play all you gotta do is be
on ps4 and join the game spot all
lowercase letters oh you got that other
interests and I'm the star you're the
stand-in
keep dreaming mini-me oh I also know
Johnny Cage and himself I love when
people let the let the intros right yeah
oh I knew that was coming
okay sometimes we get laggy fights
that's a bad
OPH dude can i play yes you know what
anyone is welcome I need to I need to do
less shadow kids I don't know how that
blocks you know what well you got that
hell yeah
flippy and Corey's got got my number
with like overall the best customization
things right now I think you've got a
maybe get those know the thing maybe so
you do 50 fatalities on one so like you
you have to your fatality on John page
50 times to get done
or at least that's what the rumors
oh no right into it dang all the mercy
reddit I'm trying
oh no I appreciate the mercy though as a
another fellow Johnny Cage fan heard
that one a lot before before I figure
out what the input was for though I get
mp11 Piers Morgan Hammett player Desk is
your opinion the game isn't worth it so
I think the game as it stands like just
playing it very good very good but there
are a lot of issues with the progression
and there already it sounds like they're
they're on their way to try to make it
work but yeah yeah I'm gonna try to keep
it just a one match so we can get
multiple people in yeah yeah that's
something we've learned for sure but it
was a very good match people fighting
over somebody heck yeah so I saw I think
the Aaron Black was the second one in
the room so I'll challenge them yeah
let's do it
let's do a fight we're streaming days
gone we streamed it earlier we got to do
a little bit of an early thing with it
and
[Music]
was that game come out is that out today
I think it's out today oh [ __ ]
I mean it's not a multiplayer game this
is this is a show where we play with
people multiplayer games well thank you
for the match Cory it was very good
but if you want to fight again stick
around because it seems like we're not
getting too many people so might have to
come back yeah yeah I feel free to stick
another character Ivan amex good time
playing is cool I haven't changed my
variation name she had I really should I
think you can do that I didn't get a
chance to put that scorpion mask oh the
fake out we thought we knew you could do
a tech yeah I've already won the first
part of the fight we're in oh well
thanks for hopping in though yeah and be
sure to come back again any other time
we we kind of fall back onto playing
fighting games a lot on Friday shows if
you like fighting games one had man to
it here we are
ooh well that's just weird too loud I
hadn't heard that one before just one
guy to another
[Applause]
yeah that's a toxic it seems like
they're definitely trying to fix the
progression but I mean also if you're
just into the way like moles on that
plays like that part of the same yeah I
really like how this place it's a lot
more similar to mine so if you like if
you like to tend a bit more because it's
speedier it might not there's that I
wish I would just wants to make sure
it's all good
right she did go back then can I bow to
each other heck yeah that's cool it's
your your you're gonna you're gonna have
a really good time it's not cool to see
that you're in black without get out of
that goop that's bad goo father's more
guilty oh the fetal blood
oh man right into it oh good I'm really
excited to see a bunch of mercies which
is this type of thing it inspires me to
want to play more air black you get so
distracted by everything that you don't
notice is ice this one that's like their
big thing oh man
like half the fatalities involve
eyeballs Oh weird very good fight I
appreciate the the mercy yeah fantastic
but stick around again I'm back out now
just we can see if there are other
people to fight yep but we might come
back to you that's a good time just the
heart is here at a master and I'm k-11
all right who else we got here la baby
face let's do it
again if you would like to join around
ps4 and you just got to search the room
game spot and come in and beat us up
yeah I've only won one match so far out
of three so that's not too bad not too
bad at all
see I've been trying to mess around okay
know a bit to try and understand him I
don't want to fall into like a new
territory because she's kind of like a I
feel bad playing him because he's like
the combo guy and it's kind of easy to
just like look you're playing the guy
who has the really long combos I can't
pull any of them off though so it's kind
of like a good balance yeah yeah hey Roy
how's it going and you're gonna do it on
xbox
oh yeah only can edit variations of
man oh man okay you can do it do
something here
GG guys cool fight is a very good time
okay bring it back here in the second
round swear swear I'll do sign
until after she did yeah yeah we didn't
want to ash for a while yes I'm very
excited just nice slam that hammer down
yeah I respect them down he hops over it
I can't believe I feel bad that I did a
really bad job which one is it cookies
gonna the face one hell yeah
Oh eyeballs it's so brutal every time
cuz it was like the first one they
showed because yeah it sets the bar so
high I love it look at this pie is cold
just he knows what he's done here I'm
gonna pick a different character because
I feel like I feel like I need to give
you a better a better fight than that
[Music]
just to just give you a better a better
run because I could tell you were just
kind of like hanging out kind of loud do
it I can't can't argue with that
yeah let's let's not spoil anything for
anyone no one likes having things
spoiled we're all here to have a good
time of hanging out
take it to the the island ruins add them
back though I don't feel like typically
you don't call back guess characters the
shell con site I win when you're using
the announcer voice I wish he did it
very good
[Music]
know what inspired me that it's pickup
come again
is that he has a mood that is just
called blue tang and no
[Music]
okay all right that's fine this is the
first round maybe I've just got like a
year's like a mental frame of Barack or
maybe I'm okay
the grab the arm void of a legs light
oh you forgot this it was really fine
we'll be okay well we can still bring
this to do it oh no oh no I thought I
could do it and I messed my inputs up
twice it's fair good fights alright well
that's damn
alright guys got to go look forward to
it alright I'm gonna back out now I'm
letting each other we are fighting
people in a lobbies if you want to play
with us and have a the game on the ps4
please join jump on in oh yeah alright
so I'm I'm 1 in 1 & 3
ok I'm keeping track of this for myself
[Music]
your totals alright
we got we got another err in black in
here I challenged you let's do the thing
good game indeed I'm no I I do kind of
have that really strong belief that like
if I win in a fighting game it's it's
good but I definitely value like like a
good fought fight even though I lose
kind of thing
she learned so much more from look at
Jax ago oh you got that young Jack's
game something yeah ask away
don't get out there and dominated brain
yeah that's true
I don't know why ever want to download
my brain though being codels wingman
won't see don't I get diplomatic
immunity pretty pretty good so far
thank you but been nice and relaxed
having a good time I'm looking forward
to this all day getting to play Mortal
Kombat finally doing a community Friday
with you guys again it's been a while
no hole should probably wait more on
those but I just get so excited when I
can play on ps4 yes with you like that
same
I kind of like objects just a little bit
more though cuz he has the beard oh
they're in black ones really good too
she's got a full oh man
the golden guns too oh no they had it
under control the whole time they knew
what they were doing bring it back I can
do something I got I got some some Jax
Tech in here somewhere
I can make it work
oh no feel kind of kind of dirty how
that works out that brings it into the
third round
what did Jax just say I don't I think he
said you're walking soups sandwich cool
you know old Jack says would you like
fries with that and that's the best
thing yeah a shadow we play games we try
and play games every Friday
heck yeah
you guys alternate systems there's a ps4
we don't finish this
it kind of kind of comes down to look
where we've got access to it yeah we'll
do like halos a good go-to for Xbox yeah
well we'll do callbacks that kind of
thing but today this is Mortal Kombat
week when playing a lot of Mortal Kombat
and finally get to play it with you guys
so I thought the best call but I could
fight though
I see Persians excited about Halo yeah
heck yeah that's always a good one cuz
everyone gets excited about it Rob will
show up and he won't have any of the
games downloaded again it'll be
fantastic when halo comes on pc though
oh my god sign up for the beta for that
I don't know if we're gonna be able to
stream it when we're in the paid up no
probably not because I was in the beta
for the changes to the don't think I
fought skull monkey yet and it says our
odds of winning or 40% we've seen the
mod coming out it's a recent Halen
mother doing I think I remember seeing
something about a halo something by
here's oh I feel like there's always
some sort of hey Lamont happening but
he'll yeah if they keep battery a lot of
halo we have fans porting it to BC I'm
curious how that's gonna go because
they're also doing the official PC stuff
now it's just
ooh now I get to see some real Jax
gameplay who should I do
no oh okay ballin okay ball out oh yeah
let's say seeing seeing all these good
Aaron black streaks you want to really
try to keep good a tear in black the
cowboy aesthetic is good it's very just
cuz you have like flashbacks - yeah the
microtransactions of bad as I've been
hearing so let's not the micro
transactions per session there honestly
again all you can use the micro
transactions is to find a specific list
of unlockables that they have in like a
store that they rotate it so you can't
even really buy your way through things
yeah more than just like the micro
transactions are they're particularly
useful and then on top of that big
[Applause]
feel like cabal is cheating also I feel
bad that the only fatality our level of
football makes it look like the tea
bagging at the end of the fight and
that's not what I'm trying to do there's
nothing you wishes ferrets that I have a
bad memory man yeah I like cabal
resident not evil since I could kick
anyone in here's ass come on in you
wanted you want prove it
get on in here I'm gonna get my ass
handed to me it's been happening the
whole stream but sometimes I get a new
fight out here well back out that was a
good fight I'm sorry that I uh bald you
I still feel really dirty about any any
time I play cabal who else do we got
here looking for a verse hey I'm down
you've been challenged let's do it if
you want to challenge me right off the
bat
that's what I'm here for my win odds are
69% and I'll take that I'll give reading
to go I'm not too worried about winning
or losing I'm I'm still at the point
where I'm like I like Johnny Cage he's
my main man boy I still want to kind of
put my hands on all the other characters
she's an interesting character but I'm
not like I'm my sexy
how everything else pans out I'm not
gonna talk about the lesson spoilers
spoilery fought in every time let this
be our last battlefield oh man
yeah like how they almost added the one
thing I really love about rare Grady I
gotta think about it every time because
Metal Gear is I really like how
it just looks so good all also I don't
think I've run into like very many such
Rihanna everyone has a past your cameras
got a real good facility for sure I
think I think you're talking about the
one where he dances and I feel like
that's a very good
[Music]
just hit the other side oh god it
doesn't matter so know that that's a
little bit well no that's okay
she needs me to go into it another round
there's still a chance all her moves
look really you but she looks like she's
gonna justice character which is kind of
interesting for me pink shadow we don't
friend requests from people at least I
don't
however we do have a GameSpot
PlayStation that you can join join Matt
and that way you'll know
man and the fatality to this one is it
all this is the fun Krueger wore out
yeah but like the pert up like is our
thing good fight oh man it's it's really
cool to see like a person who's in the
Centurion because like we were saying I
haven't seen never seen you haven't seen
anyone summon to that yeah so cuz we
were saying this is like our first
actual community friends in a long time
it gave us what community so that's
called doing gamespot community then how
do you know every fatalities so I think
you kind of just know the ones for the
characters you're you're into unless you
do to have them all committed to memory
which is very impressive
they're quite quite affluent here now
hey I think people are already lined up
to say matchmaking to us we can just get
in better taken away but if you'd like
to join the room that we're in is just
called GameSpot join in challenge us
throwdown
it'll be a good time
all right who we gonna pick this time I
want to get good with Kano because he's
disgusting so wanna pick Oh disgusting
oh we hit a button my best I thought I
thought was player one I'm like wait a
minute cameras on the other side play
hard with Kung Lao
God what gross boy coming from you that
means something oh no everyone's The
Crying pretty much pers is very good
fight her Joe if you're waiting you're
waiting by us she's not worth that by
Persia
oh no apparently she have one bar
connection oh no oh no we got combo
Cities is live and well we're here we're
doing it it's it's noob everybody yeah
heard you're just plain playing that
corporate Internet appropriate cookie
every time that's lame so I should
probably like at some point commit to
memory he knows like profit launcher I
can always just throw eggs that's always
a good counter
that shouldn't works out that way good
good I felt it we're still in it we're
still going
have an egg perfect yeah like our Panera
net
but in here I note a he's worked very
hard to make sure like to learn Excel
particular room is good because the
whole reason that K no choke god geez
okay alright that wasn't too bad we
gonna we got third match third round he
knows eating a rat off the floor that he
peed on previously it was fine boy
yeah he's disgusting and I love it
Oh
Oh No there's so many meter breaks
happening oh we got it
oh wow my goodness yeah I don't know
anything does very good match excellent
I did practice with him a little bit
earlier so I did kind of have in my mind
fantastic how to do stuff but yeah we'll
do some brutalities I dunno some with
Johnny Cage I can probably try to yeah
yeah I'm not good enough to do that oh
I'll pick Johnny Cage and I'll see if I
can but no promises because there are
some very good people in this lobby
again who are looking to fight a good
person got a match heck yeah all right
who do we fight each other except for
hail zombie it was the first one we
fought what's hail zombie man so we
could okay we could bring it back yeah
we've been hanging out for a while let's
have a have a proper run back run back
y'all I'll do my best to do a brutality
but I can't promise it I'll do it try my
best for you
Jonnie Jonnie cheap way to get aquino
clinic i feel it
let's take it to the dragon fight clubs
i feel this is a very canonical fight in
a canonical place I'm into it the bar
that Kano runs
[Music]
Heights stop sniffing around Cassio
Sonia Thank You Johnny how's the line
oh right off the bat
[Applause]
these are these are my basic johnnycakes
trips Oh No okay that's fine it's okay
as long going according to plan
I was looking healthy yeah right
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh No
nice to meet you cutting in I like his
fatal blow a lot like the weird like
kind of surf move that he does often
where he's doing it to rot away we're
doing it bring it back Oh shadow kick
beats Kino ball that's wild
try it I'm trying to try to do the thing
though
hold on did we get it hell yeah we got
it I did that for you there you go
[Music]
Johnny Cage wonderful what a what a
beautiful beautiful thing that we've
done good fight though huh I I stopped
breathing for a second because I'm oh
god he's coming back he just hit me for
like so much damn it
good fight it's a very good fight oh
thank you for allowing me to do that
brain set brutality I appreciate it
who else we got in here camera Chris I
don't think I fought you yet yeah let's
do it
would you like to try a fight I think
you should stick with it are you sure
yeah this one's almost got a 69% that's
a good odd you still got that noodle
feeling a little feeling okay alright I
might have to sit this one out today
well so all good if you do feel like
like you're like oh man I've been I want
I want to I want to take part I want to
jump in like you you get like a a moment
of inspiration I'll let you know let me
know that's all a man in Johnny Cage
well that's a real cool skin for him
I've been trying to work on a Kazakh age
so we'll do uh you know we haven't gone
to the fire guard we're already in cage
code doesn't exist without me hey hold
on dad your mom bet me you could whip my
ass this is why I'm in therapy
so cage Kahn you hadn't you had no
verdict 18 you know I'm all about caged
calm no no oh shoot I hope that it
didn't shut down the room dude that
would suck let's find out Persia does
the room get shut down
Mortal Kombat oh my going I'm like going
online and maybe you can just join the
room hopefully try joining I'm gonna
join a room I created oh look it's free
pants right there
join join the room but I created sick
fantastic we're back in it that's nice
that it doesn't get rid of it though
yeah I I'm really sad because I think
that means that I quit failed to connect
to the room always like room destroyed
hello it says even create about you oh
yeah maybe uh maybe if you refresh it
won't be there anymore
try to get there so as I dropped out I'm
gonna see you just get back in if this
doesn't work I'll just make anyone yeah
yeah feeling like from shoot well let's
just do it up just do this one in all
capital letters cuz it's the opposite
howdy
how's the movie alright we're back in
we're doing it again man
won one of these days that's a bummer we
can just rejoin the room like the option
was there but yeah I wonder if it was
like a ghost of a room or something but
mo says hey how's the game after the
update held off purchase after yeah it's
it hasn't been entirely patched yet the
actual economy balance patch was
supposed to happen either yesterday or
today I haven't seen anything happened
though and they said maybe at the latest
early next week
they have rebalanced some of the towers
though and that's actually pretty
noticeable okay Persia says she was
still in the room where the we get
booted why did we get booted why does
the universe not want us to have fun and
play with people I can't believe this
yeah using using an analog stick for
this sounds like it might be kind of a
[Music]
like the story mode of this game you
need more Johnny Cage heck yet words
that's that's the the whole thing in my
life I see more Johnny Cage
yeah the towers are ridiculous they did
some tuning to it but it's still not
great yeah purges back in the room so
it's Razorback she has not lost a single
match the game is giving me a red
warning saying you have a 30% chance to
win don't fight her
why are you fighting yeah well people
get in I'm down yeah hopefully people
get back in sorry about that
bad can't believe this your favorite
Mortal Kombat I think this might be my
favorite Mortal Kombat now but before
this it was 9 I really really liked 9 it
had a whole bunch of content in it with
a K of course I like all like probably
one of the best rosters in a Mortal
Kombat game for nine oh yeah 9s probably
my personal favorite yeah they have win
odds this game knows that Persia is
gonna probably kick my ass
half the jumps you were doing we're
trying to despecialized I'm sub-zero was
was a heck of a thing so times gonna if
it froze seems like it's waiting trying
to connect trying to connect which is
weird because we're literally what
twenty feet apart yeah right maybe
that's what it is it thinks it needs to
be further apart yeah I'm gonna McCann
so the challenge we're gonna do it again
yeah sure I guess there we go waiting
for response alright cool cool
connecting man
again maybe this is what she was talking
about where she know what's fighting her
earlier the fates are conspiring against
us and they don't want us to have fun
it's going for either quino's portal
your second fatality yeah he's got some
good stuff going on
dang I can't believe that this game is
doing this well I'm gonna move on to Red
Devil I'm gonna challenge you because I
think you are new we'll go on from there
hopefully there's no ping bill that's
fine
this is us what if the problem is just
us what if it's always been us Garan
black volume voiced by Matthew Mercer
I'm actually you think he's always by
Troy Baker mmm who you get it Matthew
Mercer's or you get Matthew Mercer of
Troy Baker is not available the longest
time which is not to diminish Matthew
Mercer but Troy Baker's standing in for
sure let's uh let's Shao Kahn
cuz I haven't got a chance to play as
him much and I want I want a chance to
say kind of messed up a bit and who
better to challenge than Earth realms
champion Liu Kang it's a very good skin
Felipe
Berthe realm is off-limits
a line in the sand boy one written in
stone ooh we're off to a good start
feeling it
okay so he's got a shoulder charge
that's like how big and swinging is
okay he's got it oh god I didn't know
like a crushing blow hey great box how's
it going hey good to see you
no way jumping late to the stream we
relate to start with streams yeah yeah
right no crime yet crime was like oh I
this I don't know what's happening
anymore the stream that happened the
double burn
still not good following that up one of
these days be able to do a thing you can
see you can't over the background
drinking yeah drink when you're at the
bar can of tusks it was a dirty boy
oh this uh this is a fatality like no
one can convince me otherwise this fatal
blow is not a fatal
that's a murder I don't know what's shop
unspun like I love the way his
animations look just because like no
gray foxes their new work schedule
prevents him from being able to watch at
11:00 what no we're just gonna have to
move the whole thing yeah yeah we have
to move all of our streams now a good
fight red as it was it was a good time I
should try I should try Lu Kang I should
give Luke a a go okay fun yeah oh good
try Persian again we could game Chris's
in here I get Persia another try
yeah let's do it see if it works
so we're up to we got 69% now that means
it's gonna work I'm Superman I see
Johnny Cage I click enter hey yeah it's
it's the best way to be and you got the
perfect face for him like I spent a lot
of time trying to find the perfect
Johnny Cage face it's oh so good so good
most the fatal blows were basically
fatalities yeah
feeling it this is it it's happening
wait a frost Brutale or Frost's fatal
blow is definitely a fatality 20% box
doesn't really like the Easter eggs
video that you did oh thank you yeah ha
is this game good I like it yeah I'm
having a very good time with it
dang Persia I can't believe this socks
um I don't think we've we fought you yet
try that let's give it a go so we played
a whole bunch earlier today you've also
got that hundred percent wind
possibility right now going on hey
spoilers for the story mode in the
Easter Egg vid no I accepted spoiler
free as far as goes a fellow chucker I
see I reference I referenced the name of
two chapters in a relief story mode
chapter three in chapter 4 but those
aren't really sports but if you
literally want to know I guess nothing
absolutely nothing about the story mode
then maybe hold off although that Easter
Egg is the last one I mentioned so you
could probably I wouldn't
three facts about that team in quote oh
heck yeah
read I'm glad that you're here for it
it's like I kind of just subtly slip it
out I was worried I missed it I set off
fellow trucker because they both use
nunchakus oh there's a line bish combat
again I throw my favorite part about
that Easter Egg video and it's sort of
like the reason we wanted to do it they
just keep referencing the movie it's
great yeah we should have listened to
that pre-fight dialogue I think that was
on me I might have gotten really excited
just about just gonna fight you have
that double burn oh no I couldn't do it
I don't have enough
that's that's a dumb thing that you
could do with those forward kicks oh I
thought I could do it
I was wrong dead wrong is a good fight
though there's a good mirror match look
at those zombie feet
who else we got in here first I'm Kay
movie the other day fresh in my mind
going yeah it there's a moment there's a
thing in the Easter Egg video that I
liked when I picked it up and actually
inside of the the Crypt I was like oh
man what is this and I instantly
recalled the thing from the movie I
think we fought rubbered yet so let's go
rubbered you've got a lot of online
match experience under your belt a
little over 69 percent chance to win but
I'm here for it
[Music]
I feel like I can't play Sonia I I'm
feeling I want to give you the like the
best I can and I feel like Johnny Cage
is the best I can
touching all the characters of those
from the 90s CG reptile yes then ideas
CG reptiles very good hell yeah paid
enough for change
I see a lot of new just in the
experience it's okay though you can
almost always count on seeing me as
Johnny Cage cuz even though I'm not boys
got some character the double pop up
don't like new yes I I always liked the
idea of mood I think it even got some
character but Elsa I can't can't get
down with him
can't a crap
[Applause]
okay this is gonna be a I don't know how
it's gonna work out
probably won't
I should have been ready for the range
oh there's that face rip again I use a
controller I'm almost a pad fighter for
every funny game I tried I tried using a
fight stick back when Street player four
was a thing and I'm like building fight
steaks I think it's really fun like I
built the custom one that I like
modified the different like boards that
I could do like all three systems but
then the problem is is that like I was
just thinking about it I was like man I
really want to like build a new board
but I'm like wait we're about to get new
systems this is like the worst time to
build a new board cuz it's kinda what
happened last time was I built a board
and then I got we had the new systems
and I was like I think that's why I
didn't used in a while because it like
new games myself yeah maybe uh part of
me wants to build one this year but part
of me wants to wait something I fought
Cain yet also played a fair amount of
online matches yeah as long as they make
them pack compared over from system to
system yeah so that was the thing was
for a little bit
mine was compatible with like ps4 mmm
cuz um it was a thing where it was like
some fighting games I forget what it was
called that you could basically like set
it to say like ham using like a legacy
stick yeah and you can do it with like
Street Fighter you can do like
Skullgirls or like couple games let you
do it but I feel like they haven't been
on top of that at this point because
they're like hey dude you just should be
she just should just work now you should
have a new one at this point
yeah well rate K was saying that Persia
was really good couldn't keep up with
her yeah Persians very very good as he
did the work habits compatible yes I
believe so they they like did a bunch of
work to make it compatible and then they
were like sharing it with some other
devs we're like allowing it I agree with
Superman de Blois I was actually talking
about this earlier the make-a-wish
mentality 99 that's like the most pure
form of what noob can do
and it's really weird that other one
yeah that they don't have that in here I
guess they have the one read the baton
to get the day the game days gone well
yeah
based on her review talking with her it
just seems like it's story it's not
really there yeah like it doesn't seem
like it's a terrible thing but
everything about Ellis from me like I
hear like yes
I feel like I cheap that out and I'm
very sorry how long is this gonna go for
more combat is a game that you always
need to learn this is dark light which
is or you don't jump to fight just like
plain enemy fighters
jumping is day so I do it instinctively
[Music]
[Music]
I love the
good fight gee there's another character
I wish I could keep good at I like the
funny fatalities too which is maybe why
I kind of gravitated towards Johnny Cage
cuz that's like his shtick
[Music]
oh yeah that it was a very mortal combat
fatality I'll for sure see you who do we
got here now
in fact Red Devil yet we did I don't
think we fought juice box though another
Johnny Cage fan with the 69% win odd
again this is great it's exactly what I
wanted all right I haven't played Jackie
yeah
[Music]
yes at least one game is so I feel weak
yeah pretty easy to use I can't wrap my
mind around her I'm sure if I maybe
spent some time with her I'd probably
get her a little bit better but at some
point don't even want to think about it
it's all you think john-boy Johnny why
meet on a Friday at 5 p.m.
I'll be tired all the time is this my
secret I'm always tired we've got the
brass knuckles
[Applause]
very good
that shouldn't worked out sure we need
borracho in this game power yeah you can
it's a hell of a thing to do you might
have discussed you had your voice when
you said that
all right over here Fox one otherwise
says default about names
oh so we haven't named these these
custom expect the meter burns funny
though yeah it kind of looks like name
of that like error in character I like
it
you almost every character I play is
accustomed it felt like the kick was
coming I don't know if this is gonna be
enough to make a difference this is
control oh come on oh it didn't do the
brutality though I didn't remember the
thing for it I don't remember any other
inputs for sewing these things you know
it was a very good fight though great is
that the borderlands 300 Flags you bet
yeah whoo I forgot to breathe again
excellent fight he has a very very good
fight yeah we're gonna be going for
about another half an hour sounds good
so if you want to pop in and play with
us
we undoubtable you have tons of spots
open in the zone yeah see I don't I
don't know if we fought this person yet
but I'm gonna challenge them anyway I'm
in let's do it
if I could return I would hate that we
said there isn't much happening next
week maybe we'll do mortal combat again
we might do it again we'll see yeah yeah
pings kind of rough but that's okay
oh my torque well we'll find a way gotta
go and games
alright see a box night thanks for
hanging out quick you have a good time
and you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna try air in black I'm gonna try
to make him work
oh yeah purge that's good point they I
just noticed that that they tell you if
they're on Wi-Fi or like connected lose
some good infinim at school which Ben
sudhi would make another Syphon Filter
you got down for another Syphon Filter
there's always room for more stealth
games since we're not getting Metal Gear
anytime soon we're the heck
I've actually never quit - sold again
without intimidate me I don't sleep very
well but still is not help still thing
you can play I guess all right let's see
here
off to a good start
scorpion scorpion a plus
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah I can ruining that head in the bag
yet huh see how he's a character from
the red dragon red dragon gang a rival
gang to the no it's gonna be a sir then
it's probably it's probably us they say
we're not booted out of the lobby and
since it didn't say the same thing it
said last yeah we're good okay shoot
well that sucks I don't think we've
fought this person let's move it right
along let's do it
sorry about the disconnect the lag got
real intense there for a bit
gato can't wait for endgame great stream
has their awesome piece thanks for
hanging out Jason hope to see you around
again enjoy the movie it's connector
quit I'm gonna say well either
disconnect or quit due to how bad the
connection you know what we'll get a
full front there in black so I'll give
them a good words appreciates your black
red dead very
oh thanks yet I want to make something
that was definitely read dead reference
but I didn't want to be like too too on
the nose but he just boiler in it oh man
OPA guessing I'll pop you before you can
run count of three
punch edgy boys being edgy matches you
can make your own fatality well they
actually didn't have that have a
fatality yeah I feel like
yeah also Aaron black best throw in a
game I love that throw so much soul of
these shoots a burden between yeah
[Music]
also it's weird that Aaron Black has
like a grayish attack ignoring between a
combo is like if you do this way back
[Applause]
get those eggs out of here this may be a
mistake but I got to do it once at least
once today okay I don't know how to do
Spinelli so I gotta just do a hair but
you gotta do a mercy at least once
you know MA come on what I loved you I
hated my mom all right
good fight though good good fight that
mercy is more of a troll move oh yeah
really is it's really what Mercy's are
for the religious meant to tetryl look
unless someone's got very similar health
and you both don't have you're like fail
blow or whatever it kind of seems like
it is a bit of a punk move for sure can
you do Mercy's forever I think you can
only do it once I think you're only
doing one CF I don't think we fought you
Skywalker the rides with Skywalker yeah
I'm gonna say I'm I'm excited for like
we get to like out like a main stage Evo
situation and then someone mercy someone
and ends up losing oh my god dude the
only thing worse would be as if you pled
guilty here and got it before the round
was over that would be so good if that
happened yeah right I'm here well
welcome Raymond it's good to have you
Evos Cassie
we had a request for her I'm not very
good with her either but I've been
working on her so I kind of understand
some of the stuff she has probably
disabled mercy I hope not
I want drama I want the Evo drama yeah
it's like when they summon Shenron
persia finally lost the match let's just
go all right gotcha no patience for
Imperial [ __ ] oh hell yeah
drag him Cassie
[Applause]
that chainsaw out of here whoa no her
baton is fatal blows awesome very good
oh boy Oh No
why would you do this why little combat
why damn Mortal Kombat Skywalker I'm so
sorry this is a really good fight going
on yikes did you get booted again I got
booted again what well there's a week
between now and the next one if we
decide to do this again we didn't try to
figure it out this is going on this
unless it's something on Mortal Kombat
side which it probably isn't I'm willing
to bet that it's probably us because
everyone else is still left in the room
yeah oh [ __ ] oh really we find each
other again I'm gonna try to get back in
if we're if we I'm gonna get into the
room do it again I hope it just lets me
join back if I can't drive back I'll
make another one and we'll have you jump
in and we'll give it the run back
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna make it
man I can't believe this I can't believe
this
Ed Boon gonna do although our case again
all right so if you guys want to jump
room again here we are
it's game spot all lowercase here we go
was also black hat and spider-man ps4
shoe been busy I can't believe this
it did give me the poon only real go uh
bridge leader uh yeah some of the
history of us have been taken offline
for I'm not entirely sure why but we are
those should hopefully be back up soon
I'm I think there's just something weird
going on that they need to be checked
about hopefully they'll be back
see you tube nonsense failed to create
them sorry if you were trying to watch
it though you what
lame spot no one's gonna take this one
it's lame spot now it worked just four
at all right uh lame spot in all capital
letters please join Skywalker if I see
pop up all I'll reach Alan Jon we're
here for another 18 minutes 18 minutes
heck yeah juice boxes back in I'm
assuming get Skywalker get that run back
there we go bully it will work it's it's
a solid connection it's a new room it's
fresh it's exciting we'll get the run
back and they pick Cassie again
everything will be okay
oh you say you showed them our video
whenever you want to be one of those
really yeah like I said that should
hopefully be back up nicely alright
we've recreated the match down to the
letter same mindset same everything
we're set we're good just got no
patience for Imperial oh we got the same
one
then and then then you say drag dragger
alright now you have to just recreate
the exact match perfect perfect
everything's going exactly an hour I
really like that like inverted katana
skin that's really good
oh no these slam this thing down again
cuz I'm gonna be really intensive
do you guys like the new stages in MK 11
yeah I like the stage selection set for
April oxys and Jack Riggs I'm gonna give
her go I haven't really done much very
much
Hey the way we're going
oh man
oh yeah oh yeah she's available too
ready right here
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah oh shoot I should
actually get Oracle yeah I've watched
you replay through like the whole family
[Music]
oh I jumped in on it like a fool I am
was a good fight though
and I'm glad that we got to do the run
personally because that's the thing that
I fell into every time when I fought her
I'd love jumping in Mortal Kombat I
can't stop to save my life uh it was
good though it was a very good fight
from history want to really like your
channel I'm glad that you're here and
you having a good time I don't think we
fought you yet I'll pick I'll pick
Jackie plus we got some some Jackie
glasses see if I can I can make some 69
percent chance to lose so we're already
in all right
noobs on loose the beautiful stories of
the Brier I like the stage a lot it
might be my feet like it's not my
favorite time to fight in us my favorite
to be in like I want I want to go here
I'm in here just a good fight heck yeah
I'm looking forward to it
yeah she's dead [ __ ] wow factor' soul
is mine yeah okay okay
new noobs got a crystal guts I don't
know why I'm surprised that she has
oh that's not the range I'm looking for
oh my goodness Oh run back oh okay yeah
okay she can shoot Rockets straight down
man how can you fight us you just join
our Lobby about another ten spot
not close enough oh okay third round
we're doing it three you want Lane spot
getting spot lane spot okay there are
three all those rooms are still okay so
that's that's important sham Winfred
that n we see infinite apology addition
I don't think
good fight who wasn't tensed at that
time so you know you know what's a good
fight when you forget to breathe that's
that's a good mark I think uh Marvel vs.
DC one would be pretty good yeah I'd be
into it
I think if another problem was to handle
that some I'm always down for more
versus type games yeah see who we got
here
Persians asleep just she lost she lost
her game and she's done we got here we
anyone we have in haven't played yen's
I don't think so I don't think we've
played against Aaron black in a while
start bringing it back on all right
sounds good I guess for the the last two
matches all I'll try to do Johnny Cage
I'll bring I'll bring what I want to be
my age
it's got some good air in black loadouts
sink to the that ain't how it said
whatever you say around gonna shoot off
that 10 gallon mouth
okay some good some push back and forth
there for a bit oh it is pretty late I
keep thinking that it's still kind of
11:05 30-man nights off funny games so
nice
Thanks I'm the star welllet's dreams
like today be a reoccurring thing we're
not planning on it was today we're
usually gonna be at our home combat
Lisa's why can't I on subscribe to this
channel
why would you wanted yes that's the real
question you just hit that because
that's a good thing to do enough
that like door-knocking combo is a plus
like top top to your ear in black combos
for sure I see you guys later in the day
though I always work at 11:00 yeah I did
the one for tell you I can always count
on my check the like like it's it's just
he's posed in a weird way that's not
normal his arm looks like it's broken
and I love it good good fight though
very good fight all right they can do
one more one more one will fight see who
we got on fire we'll wrap it up all
right starting a job this week won't be
oh yeah man that's the power well we'll
be sure to shout you out either way if
you ever watch the vod's that way you'll
you'll feel like you're you're still
there we're doing it eleven still
no I don't think we fought John Diddy
it's been challenged I didn't even need
to challenge there on top of it let's go
see sub potenti notifications turn on I
mean but you I wish we knew that's yes
same feel like we know I feel like
YouTube's constantly changing the way
things work get people who are like I
didn't have notifications turn on but I
was getting them or I do have
notifications explicitly turned on and
I'm still not getting them saying like
who knows man YouTube this is just weird
here we know zg games make ten more if I
can make them time I'm sorry man we got
wrap-up for the day but we will be back
next week next week I think we'll
probably make now I just think we'll
probably make a Mortal Kombat 2 I think
we'll just do another little combat one
keep it going for a little bit it's kind
of the big multiplayer game does happen
unless something else pops up on her she
says or Skullgirls
could could bring extra cool girls again
dang I would like Sam so I just like to
see people trying to try to be purchased
you have to call the title video try to
be whoa No
such a fast tornado man hey have him
come on vaio be good time what's up my
name is Johnny Cage I got the most
unsafe moves in the game just watch just
stuff it every time
[Applause]
okay last round we got right we're in
there it's a good match yeah
Oh end it end it with the nut punch - I
got panicked I didn't know what to do no
that's I mean it's it's a stream with
Johnny Cage on a thumbnail you gotta
cool it's a very good blanks one way to
end this very very good everybody who
hopped in here that was great that we
kept having to make new lobbies cuz
something's up with our internet
hopefully that kids will figure out
what's up with that if that is the game
or if that was us I will get that sorted
we'll be back next week for probably
Mortal Kombat 11 unless Persia convinces
us to do Skullgirls yeah why is oh yeah
look forward we stream normally at 11:00
every weekday say exactly what we're
doing but I know we have some cool stuff
having stuff on the way in the middle of
the week that should be pretty exciting
so look forward to that and
yeah play yakuza plating and roppa yeah
don't be a fool stay in school do all
those things enjoy the movie
[Music]
you
[Music]